good morning everybody breaking news
this morning last few seconds the UK
government has just announced its
launching evacuation flights for British
Nationals stuck in Sudan after a
ceasefire came into Force let's get more
from uh eustra who is in Djibouti and
also Alistair who's standing by for us
in Cyprus this morning Alistair to you
first of all if I may the Brits are
coming
they are as you say James cleverly the
foreign secretary has announced this in
the last few seconds releasing a
statement from the foreign office I will
read you some of it they are say they
Convent are commencing an evacuation
effort to help British Nationals leave
Sudan from today the flights will depart
from an Airfield outside the capital
Khartoum we assume that that is the same
Airfield that was used over the weekend
which is about 30 kilometers north of
the city they will be open to British
passport holders priority will be given
to family groups with children and
elderly or individuals with medical
conditions they would take the priority
and the contact will be made with
anybody who the British government
believes is eligible for evacuation now
we've just seen within the last eight or
nine minutes an Airbus a400m which is a
big military transport aircraft take off
from here we do know that that will be
one of the aircraft used in this
evacuation Mission they will also use
the C-130 Hercules so the same airframes
that were used over the weekend when
British diplomats were brought out I
think this base are in fact Couture in
the Eastern Mediterranean will be key in
this operation it's about a three and a
half hour flight time pretty much
directly south down towards Khartoum so
we don't know how many planes are going
to be used what we do know is that
there's around about we're told 4 000
British passport holders trapped in
Sudan so that will take either many many
shuttles to and from or it will take an
awful lot of aircraft to go in in one go
in order to get them out but after days
of waiting finally for the civilians
trapped in Sudan the flights are now
underway and in the air okay thanks for
the update obviously more detail coming
very shortly yusra in the meantime
what's the situation on the ground
the situation is on the on the ground is
that many planes have come and gone and
evacuated foreign Nationals to safety
but no pla no British plane has arrived
on this Airfield to do so the Brits that
we have spoken to have said that they
haven't received any communication they
haven't been told they keep receiving
the same message over and over again so
cleverly's uh tweet James cleverly's
tweet saying that they will be
communicating to Brits we're yet to see
if that's if that happens if there's
mass communication to the scale that is
required and it's also important to note
that many Brits have already started to
make the arduous journey to Port Sudan
to try and evacuate by sea this is a
very tough road with a lot of
checkpoints both from both sides of the
coin very very dangerous so it is too
little too late for some we spoke to a
Brit here and other foreign Nationals
who told us just how difficult their
escape was